we begin with breaking news from the uk
where it's been confirmed that prime
minister boris johnson will face a
confidence vote later on monday the
challenge to his leadership has been
triggered by discontent within his own
conservative party johnson has faced
calls to resign over a series of
scandals it includes a number of parties
held during the height of the uk's
coronavirus lockdown
a conservative party official says that
he's received enough letters by mps for
the vote
the threshold of 15 to the parliamentary
party seeking a vote of confidence in
the prime minister has been passed
therefore a vote of confidence will take
place
within the rules of the 1922 committee
that vote will take place this evening
in the house of commons between six and
eight o'clock
and we will announce the result shortly
thereafter
there will be arrangements for proxy
votes for any colleagues who can't be
present in person
in westminster and will native high
colleagues of those arrangements in the
near future
al jazeera's jonah hull joins us now on
the line from london jonah
we have to make it clear here that this
isn't a wider parliamentary vote of of
confidence in boris johnson this is
his own party and it's about his
leadership and if he's removed as leader
after that vote then he
can no longer be prime minister
that's right this is a secret ballot uh
conducted among conservative party mps
it is an in uh in person vote uh albeit
a secret vote there is a ballot box
specifically for this very purpose it
hasn't happened very often in the past
but it will be hauled out
of the cupboards in the 1922 committee
room in the house of commons where mps
tory mps regularly meet
and for that two-hour period they will
file in and out of the 1922 committee
room and cast their votes as to whether
they believe boris johnson uh should
continue as their leader whether they
continue to have confidence in him as
the leader of the party and of course
the leader of the country now
uh there is a magic number we've already
had one magic number 54 triggering this
vote the next magic number is 180
that is 50
plus one of the parliamentary party mps
who must show confidence in the prime
minister in order for him to continue uh
we are told by graham brady the chairman
of the 22 committee that the account
will happen immediately after the vote
this evening
and that an announcement of the result
will take place shortly uh thereafter
if of course boris johnson does retain
the confidence of a majority of mps uh
his authority will be dented no doubt
but he will continue then as prime
minister and will be safe in theory from
this sort of challenge for a further 12
months under the rules as they are now
if he loses that vote uh well then his
time as prime minister will be up uh it
will trigger a potentially lengthy
leadership contest within the
conservative party that could go on
through the summer and it's expected
that he would continue as a caretaker
prime minister until the new leader is
elected after controversies that date
back months now why is this vote of
confidence happening now
well it's all come to a head in the last
few weeks really perhaps a couple of
months uh over the law believed
party gates scandal parties that took
place in downing street and other
government buildings during periods of
lockdown he was found boris johnson
himself to have illegally taken place at
taking part in one event by the police
then there was a report by a senior
civil servant sue gray that found
failures of leadership at the top of
number 10 downing street and a culture
of drinking
there were questions there are still
questions over whether boris johnson
lied to parliament an offense that would
require his resignation but finally on
top of all of this in the last couple of
weeks new polling that shows the party
is likely to lose two key by-elections
in the next couple of weeks that suggest
boris johnson is no longer the electoral
asset that he once was the man who
powered this party to victory in 2019
and ultimately that will be the crucial
test for mps if they believe he is no
longer the electoral asset he was well
then they will want him gone al
jazeera's jonah hull reporting live
there from london jonah many thanks
indeed